thank you
it's nice you look beautiful thank you
how are you
nice
they always do that when a pregnant
woman comes out
uh well we have to talk about that
you've been uh all of the news lately uh
you are expecting your second child yes
yeah how do you feel I feel okay yeah
yeah I feel all right yeah you've been
doctor yeah it's good I'm glad you know
it's weird uh I've been through this
twice I have two kids and going to the
doctor they have all this amazing
equipment where they can almost show you
too much of your child at an early stage
yeah because it's been it's been five
years since I had my first and now they
have all this new technology they have
like the 3D ultrasound which is supposed
to be like yeah I want to see it and
it's like you there's a reason that you
can't this the reason this is not
see-through yeah because that thing's
it's not cooked yet yeah yeah it's
horrifying you see the 3D ultrasound
you're like oh it's a lava monster
what's happening did you see did you
have well you know yeah they had just
they didn't have it for my daughter but
when my son uh came along who's born at
the same time as Alice uh uh and they've
played together uh uh they had the 3D
for for my son Beckett and it freaked me
out it really did because it did look
like special effects from a monster
movie or something it's like a chance to
bond with the little horrifying Golem
inside you yeah
now you did something this is a very
brave I'm told that you brought uh yeah
I'll show you It's upsetting how good I
always like to hear that It's upsetting
I'll show it to you 3D ultrasound 3D
this is the 3D ultrasound of
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it
I'm inside you
you're feeding me right now
every day I grow
stronger as you grow weaker
good God uh well tell me how I know I've
met Alice on many occasions and uh very
beautiful and Bright Child what is she
like now does she like is she a reader
does she like books she loves books if
there's no TV
right the one you four it's unfair any
Einstein would have chosen TV over books
I thought I would have chosen SpongeBob
yeah Farmer Boys and it's very good yeah
but I'm sure she loves look she took a
um she took a book out of the little
preschool Library recently uh to bring
home true together and it was called uh
my working mom and the cover of the book
was a cartoon witch at a cauldron and
that's the mom the mom in the book is a
witch
and then the whole book was I was
reading it to her I was like okay and
the book's like my mom fly flies away on
her broom to lots of meetings and
sometimes she's busy and she won't let
me near her cauldron and it was like I
was horrified as I am a working mom I
was like it's a witch yeah and so I was
trying to be really you know cool about
it I was like did you get this did you
pick this book because Mommy works and
she's like yeah
I was like okay and then we were reading
and then it was time a couple days later
take it back and I was like you know I I
just want to say that this this book
kind of hurt my feelings and and and and
and she's looking at me she goes mom I
can't read I thought it was a Halloween
book
I was like a witch green lady get over
yourself yeah I had this whole like
breakdown for nothing that's all about
me